bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à strasbourg pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo émission spéciale notre
invité guy verhofstadt ancien premier
ministre de belgique président de
l'alliance des démocrates et des
libéraux ici au parlement européen avec
lui reparler déchéance de nationalité
pour les binationaux auteurs de crimes
et délits un terroriste vous le savez en
france l'assemblée nationale discute le
texte cette semaine qu en est-il en
europe et notamment en belgique la loi
belge permet déjà la déchéance mais
uniquement pour ceux qui ne sont pas les
belges ou qui ont acquis la nationalité
par naturalisation
on va le voir l'efficacité de la mesure
est contestée en dix ans une dizaine de
binationaux et ainsi étaient déchus de
la nationalité belge
puis on s'intéressera à la crise des
réfugiés depuis un an un million de
migrants traverser la méditerranée
comment faire face à l'afflux guy
verhofstadt et sa proposition radicale
créer une force d'urgence européenne
rapide placée sous la responsabilité de
la commission est composée de deux mille
fonctionnaires ou agents nationaux
on reviendra aussi sur ce mini sommet
franco belge consacrée à la lutte contre
le terrorisme
manuel valls et son homologue belge
charles michel côte à côte lundi à
bruxelles le premier ministre français
qui plaide pour un pacte européen de
sécurité
on écoute tout de suite les deux
premiers ministres
des décisions ont été prises sur le plan
européen les dames et rationnelle
derniers mois mais à nos yeux ça ne va
pas assez vite et c'est des gens ne sont
pas suffisamment opérationnel rapidement
sur le terrain
l'espace schengen doit être un espace de
sécurité pour garantir cela il faut
mobiliser des moyens par exemple aux
frontières extérieures de l'union europé
les orientations ont été prises pour par
exemple mettre en place des
gardes-frontières européens pour
renforcer les capacités d'action les
capacités d'intervention l'europe dans
ce moment-là doit montrer qu'à la
hauteur capables de prendre pleinement
sa part dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme de protéger ses citoyens
elle doit dont s'organiser pour relever
ce défi car oui la réponse aux menaces
actuelles
ce n'est pas moins d'europe c'est plus
d'euros alors nous a rejoints sur ce
plateau guy verhofstadt ancien premier
ministre de belgique et président de
l'alliance des démocrates et des
libéraux pour l'europe au parlement
européen c'est toujours un plaisir de
vous recevoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
je dis à nos téléspectateurs que vous
sortez un livre bientôt aux éditions
plon le mâle européens dont convient
d'écouter les deux premiers ministres
ils ont énuméré aussi les mesures qu'ils
entendent défendre ensemble au niveau
européen pour lutter contre le
terrorisme il ya d'abord le le pnr qui
recense au niveau européen les données
concernant les passagers aériens vous
êtes pour on a voté pour mais ça ne veut
pas dire que le système est déjà
opérationnel parce que c'est une
directive et cette directive à prendre
deux ans trois ans pour le faire
appliquer c'est pour cette raison que je
suis en train d'essayer d'obtenir dans
la commission européenne qu'ils sortent
déjà une sorte d'obligation des changes
entre les différents services au niveau
national parce que avoir 28 pnr ça ne
donne pas encore la certitude que les
services secrets ou les services de
police font savoir ce que les autres
savent donc il faut une échange
obligatoire d'information ce qui montre
pour le moment cruellement dans dans le
dispositif
il ya aussi cette volonté de modifier
les règles de l'espace de circulation
schengen afin d'instaurer de manière
systématique et obligatoire le contrôle
aux frontières extérieures y compris
pour compris pour les ressortissants
européens extérieur ça c'était
absolument nécessaire parce que le
problème avec la crise des réfugiés
pour le moment c'est quand même qu'il
n'ya pas une bonne gestion pour ne pas
dire il n'y a pas de gestion de la
frontière entre la grèce et la turquie
et la proposition est donc je suis
content d'entendre encore une fois les
deux premiers ministres qui disent oui
il faut une solution européenne c'est
clair pour protéger cette frontière il
faut tout de suite qu'une force rapide
est de venise en place on va en parler
entière sur la frontière
et ça c'est une solution européenne
s'est pas au niveau national on parlait
en seconde partie d'émission dans ce
mini sommet manuel valls a assuré aussi
n'avoir jamais douté dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme de la volonté du
gouvernement belge dans la lutte
antiterroriste alors que l'image du pays
et endommagé à l'étranger par les
connexions belge des attentats de paris
ça vous a agacé cette image qu'on a
donné à la bête je suis que voulait pas
trop parler de des affaires reds cette
image qu'on a donné à la belgique d'un
turbo une paix que plane
voilà que tournante du terrorisme c'est
pas sérieux parce que par exemple la
tente a donné mouche donc que cet
attentat contre le musée juif de russell
oui c'était planifié a pas à paris comme
ça et il faut savoir les terroristes ils
ne connaissent pas les frontières et
donc ça n'a aucun sens de commencer à se
bagarrer entre les différents états
membres de l'union
plus tôt il faut en tirer les leçons et
les leçons à en tirer
c'est mettre en place des capacités au
niveau européen par exemple au niveau de
l'information de durand sont des
informations qui sont nécessaires et de
l'intelligence dont on a besoin
ça il faut faire aussi au niveau
européen ça n'a aucun sens que certains
services de renseignement et certains
services de police savent quelque chose
mais que les autres leurs collègues en
belgique en allemagne en france ne le
savent pas et donc créer cette capacité
c'est ça la priorité pour le monde
et donc il et puis il ya la déchéance de
nationalité arme de dissuasion massive
pas sûr annoncé trois jours après les
attentats du 13 novembre le projet de
françois hollande d'étendre la déchéance
de nationalité aux binationaux né
français et de l'inscrire dans la
constitution divise aujourd'hui
profondément la classe politique et la
société civile vue de belgique les
débats qui émerge sur les questions de
sécurité d'égalité et de liberté ont un
air de déjà vu et pour cause
le pays a déjà mis cette idée de
déchéance sur la table au début de
l'année après les attentats de janvier à
paris et une action anti terroriste à
verviers près de liège leur portage en
belgique de céline martel
l'attaqué a eu lieu ce matin dans les
locaux de charlie hebdo 12 morts 20
blessés 7 janvier 2015
la belgique avec le monde entier sous le
choc des attentats de charlie hebdo et
de l'hyper cacher la belgique en alerte
maximum huit jours plus tard un projet
d'attentât et des jouets à verviers dont
la province de liège une cellule
jihadiste et démantelé nouveau choc dans
la foulée s'organise une réunion
interministérielle pour muscler
l'arsenal des lois antiterroristes 12
mesures et parmi elles la déchéance de
nationalité
sous le coup de l'émotion la
chancellerie annonce qu'elle s'étendra à
tous les bi nationaux y compris ceux qui
sont nés en belgique
toute personne qui bénéficient de deux
nationalités entraîne la nationalité
belge peut faire l'objet d'un tel
retrait de nationalité
le projet de loi arrive devant le
parlement
et comme en france le débat s'enflamme
aux politiques antiterroristes que nous
aurions dû mettre en place bien plus tôt
nous avons des doutes quand pour retrait
de nationalité vis-à-vis d'une personne
qui vit depuis toujours chez nous à
l'origine de la défiance pour tous les
binationaux le parti élevé à un parti
nationaliste qui appartient la coalition
gouvernementale
lorsque quelqu'un se met en dehors de la
démocratie et c'est de détruire la
démocratie la démocratie doit être apte
à se défendre il faut quand même pas
oublier qu'il s'agit de personnes qui
ont commis des actes atroces
un argument qui ne convaincra pas la
majorité les parlementaires vont
finalement limiter la déchéance aux
seuls belges naturalisés
en revanche ils vont étendre le champ de
la déchéance jusqu'à présent limité au
crime
elle va pouvoir s'appliquer à toutes les
infractions terroristes punis d'au moins
cinq ans de prison
on a une panoplie d'infraction
terroristes qui est de plus en plus
larges comme la collaboration à une
entreprise terroriste
le financement d'une entreprise
terroriste mais aussi la propagande
terroriste
l'aide que l'on accorde à quelqu'un pour
que celui ci rejoignent un groupe
terroriste si vous partez en série
manifestement ce n'est pas pour faire du
tourisme
il ya de fortes chances que ça s'inscrit
dans un projet terroriste c'est un délit
en droit pénal belge
et si vous êtes condamné pour ce délit
et bien vous pouvez faire également
l'objet d'une déchéance de la
nationalité belge
la déchéance une sanction cependant
symbolique pour beaucoup ludivine pons
you et chroniqueuse judiciaire au
journal le soir
elle a étudié de près les filières
djihadistes belge pour cette journaliste
pas de doute la déchéance de nationalité
est une mesure cosmétique inapplicable
la plupart des terroristes impliqués
dans les derniers attentats par exemple
saleh ibrahim abdeslam qui eux sont
français ils ont toujours vécu à
bruxelles est donc pour eux forcément ça
ne va pas s'appliquer dans le cas d'
about about belge est né en belgique l'a
vécu en belgique
donc cette loi ne s'appliquerait pas non
plus
aujourd'hui seuls deux procédures pour
déchéance de nationalité sont en cours
dont celui de la plus célèbre des
salafistes belge
malika el aroud son visage est associé
au terrorisme depuis des années
deux fois veuve de kamikazes islamistes
elle a été condamnée à huit ans de
prison pour l'organisation d'une filière
vers l'afghanistan depuis sa cellule
elle prépare activement sa défense avec
l'aide de son avocat maître nicolas
cohen
malika el aroud ce sens belge veut
rester belge et n'envisage pas un retour
au maroc vert où est ce qu'on va laisser
est-ce qu'on peut seulement être mais
c'est cette personne vers le pays en
question
on sait que le maroc a une pratique
constante systématique depuis de
nombreuses années mais d'arrêter et le
torturer systématiquement les personnes
poursuivies pour terrorisme
malika el aroud aura fini de purger sa
peine fin 2016
elle devrait savoir d'ici là si elle
garde la nationalité belge
malgré les nouvelles lois de l'été
dernier le débat n'est toujours pas clos
en belgique après les attentats de
novembre à paris et alors qu'elle
pointait du doigt la communauté de
molenbeek
le parti nationaliste nva a relancé la
piste de la déchéance pour tous les
binationaux nous on souhaite aller plus
loin ma proposition de loi concerne en
tout cas également les personnes qui
sont en étage un débat national aux
actions familier et qui va s'inviter
dans l'hémicycle français à partir de
cette semaine
guy verhofstadt j'ai envie de vous
demander est-ce que ça a servi à quelque
chose la déchéance de nationalité pour
la lutte contre le terrorisme en
belgique
en tout cas je vais pas me mêler dans la
discussion qui est en train de se
produire en france pour le moment sur
cette proposition va personnellement je
vous donne l'exemple belge sur l'exemple
elle a vu un reportage c'est pas ça qui
va résoudre le problème terroriste
le problème terroriste c'est d'abord en
finir avec les conflits
d'où viennent les terroristes où ils
sont alimentés par ces zones de conflits
de la série naturellement est la
première liste des pays tiers et et
deuxièmement ce qu'il faut faire c'est
s'organiser au niveau européen encore
une fois on a une espèce chaîne
ça donne une liberté de de se promener à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne mais
on n'a pas ni une une des gardes
frontière commune et on n'a pas une
un système d'asile commune on n'a pas
une capacité de renseignement qui est
comme une europe c'est ça qui monte pour
moi ça ce sont des choses qui sont
beaucoup plus importantes que le projet
qui est en train de se discuter enfin on
va passer notre temps à des sujets
strictement européen ça va vous faire
plaisir donc il ya eu la crise des
migrants la solidarité face aux migrants
à l'épreuve des fins on l'a peut-être un
peu oublié mais il ya quatre mois
l'europe trouvé un accord pour la
répartition de 160 mille migrants
où en est on aujourd'hui en europe qui
jouent le jeu et qu'ils jouent pas le
jeu
on regarde et on réagit juste après
depuis un an un million de migrants
traverser la méditerranée
il y a quatre mois un plan d'urgence est
lancée par la commission européenne le
plan européen ne concerne qu'une petite
partie de ces réfugiés
les 28 pays membres ont deux ans pour se
répartir
cent soixante mille migrants originaires
de trois pays la syrie l'irak et
l'erythrée bilan bout de quatre mois
un peu plus de 400 migrants étaient
accueillis dans le cadre de ce programme
c'est très peu il y a les pays qui ne
jouent pas le jeu et n'ont prévu aucune
place d'accueil pour les réfugiés de ce
programme la croatie la république
tchèque le danemark la hongrie l'estonie
la slovénie ou la slovaquie
ce sont les états qui posent problème
sont les égoïsmes nationaux c'est la
volonté de dire je préfère laisser aux
autres la responsabilité de l'accueil
plutôt que d'assumer ma part donc au
fond dans ce dossier là il ya un manque
terrible d'europe mais c'est bien les
états qui nous empêche on a globalement
trois états qui font leur boulot
l'allemagne la suède et l'autriche et en
france
comment cela se passe paris s'était
engagé à ouvrir ses portes à 24 milles
puis trente mille réfugiés sur deux ans
bilan au bout de 4 noir un peu plus
d'une soixantaine de personnes
accueillies
le problème peut de migrants de le
rester en france 24 mille réfugiés c'est
ce qu'ils accueillent l'allemagne en
deux semaines nous on veut les
accueillir sur deux ans on est soixante
cinq millions l'allemagne c'est ce
qu'ils accueillent sur deux semaines ils
sont 80 millions donc on ne prend pas
notre juste part
mais à force d'avoir un discours au fond
très ambigu voire de défiance de rejet
deux des réfugiés évidemment ils ont
plus envie de venir dans notre pays le
problème se situerait aussi en amont
dans ce que l'europe appelle les
hotspots ces centres de répartition sont
enregistrés et orienter les migrants des
hotspots qui n'envoient pas les migrants
là où il le faut
faute de moyens le plan européen prévoit
11 hotspots dans les deux pays qui se
trouve en première ligne
l'italie et la grèce or seuls 4
fonctionne trois en italie et seulement
1 en grèce cette semaine au parlement
européen guy verhofstadt tape du poing
sur la table devant les députés
européens et les membres de la
commission le président du groupe des
démocrates et libéraux fait une
proposition radicale pour résoudre la
crise des migrants hiking wii en un bon
jack
je pense que nous faisons fausse route
nous nous pourvoyons mais nous ne
pouvons pas régler les problèmes comme
ça la commission elle dit oui les grecs
s'améliore ils contrôlent mieux les
frontières c'est peu au regard des
l'évaluation faite par votre commission
européenne elle a présenté une analyse
qui porte sur le contrôle aux frontières
entre la grèce et la turquie
un contrôle qui ne fonctionne pas les
personnes ne sont pas enregistrées c'est
la raison pour laquelle on retrouve des
milliers de jeunes réfugiés mal document
d'europol
on a des personnes qui ne sont pas
retenu ce dans de bonnes conditions
y a pas de distinction entre migrants
économiques et réfugiés
ça ne fonctionne pas notre proposition
est donc très simple vous devez utiliser
l'article 78 du traité il vous donne la
possibilité de prendre les mesures
d'urgence et de vous organiser pour les
frontières avec une force de réaction
rapide
c'est à l'europe de faire secondes assez
facile de dire oui les grecs vont
s'améliorer on va faire des
recommandations aux autorités grecques
va voir dans trois mois on sait ce qui
va y avoir dans trois mois on va avoir
encore trois cent mille réfugiés
iron arrivés en grèce ça marche pas doit
donc prendre nos responsabilités
utiliser l'article 78 tout de suite en
conseil le 18 février il y a dix jours
jean claude juncker a rappelé à l'ordre
les pays européens chaque semaine douze
mille migrants supplémentaires arrivent
en grèce un plan d'urgence qui ne
démarre pas et ce sont les filières
clandestines qui se développe
voilà guy verhofstadt j'en veux vous
demander est ce que l'europe peine à
tenir ses promesses en matière d'accueil
des migrants ajam excuses c'est les
états membres qui ne tiennent pas leurs
promesses
ils ont fait un accord a dit tout à
l'heure ils ont fait un accord sur 160
mille réfugiés à la repartir alors plus
ou moins 400 on a trouvé une plate ou
plus ou moins 400 ça ne va pas du tout
donc on est vraiment sûr dans la main en
train de se de d2 de suivre une la
mauvaise direction dans cette affaire
vous avez une proposition radicale
amical et une une force d'urgence
européenne rapide avec 2000 films à ses
actionnaires c'est quoi c'est quoi c'est
quoi c'est 2000 fonctionnaires et les
gens qui vont aller à la frontière gréco
turque et qu'ils font c'est là où le
problème se pose c'est là où le problème
se pose il y a le soi-disant quatre
centres de réception en réalité il n'ya
qu'une les autres ne fonctionne en grèce
arrivent en ce qui concerne la
dégustation des réfugiés ça ne se fait
pas il n'ya pas contrôler aussi au
niveau de la sécurité
quand on passe la frontière donc ma
proposition est très simple plutôt que
de continuer à parler de cette garde
frontières européens crayon là tout de
suite on a un article dans le traité
c'est l'article 78
mais c'est quoi ces des fonctionnaires
européens ou cdd et a envoyé à ses deux
buts une actualisation des moyens est
fait on a fait parce que cette frontière
gréco turque est une frontière
extérieure de l'union et son que c'est
la co responsabilité de tous les états
membres et donc l'idée c'est d'envoyer
2000 agents 2000 factionnaires c'est eux
qui vont alors gérer la frontière c'est
eux qui vont faire les contrôles c'était
qu'ils vont faire russie la différence
la distinction entre ceux qui sont de
vrais réfugiés et qui peuvent plus
apparaître look et en europe et par
des migrants économiques qui n'ont pas
droit à entrer dans l'union européenne
selon les règles actuelles parce que
pour moi ça se mélange pour on ne sait
pas on ne sait même pas eu à quelques
milliers de jeunes réfugiés de d'enfants
qui sont entrés probablement et qui
peut-être sont dans les mêmes de
d'organisations criminelles
aujourd'hui donc c'est une c'est une
catastrophe
et pour en finir c'est très simple le 18
février ça les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement va prendre la décision de
créer cette force rapide d'intercesseur
sa force il faut l'accord quand même de
la grèce si la grèce ne veut pas si la
caisse ne veut pas elle se met
automatiquement en dehors de chaîne
c'est clair
en plus ce n'est pas une une agression
de la grèce un problème de sous traiter
la souveraineté nationale il n'existe
pas de souveraineté nationale quand on
parle de frontière extérieure de l'union
européenne puisque il est une c'est une
cause commune c'est une responsabilité
commune
donc ce qu'il faut faire c'est le faire
ensemble naturellement avec les
autorités grecques mais tout de suite
prendre cette décision d'envoyer et
alors il ya une deuxième grand volet
dans notre plan une autre décision qui
doit être prise c'est plutôt de que
donner ces 3 milliard d'euros au
gouvernement d'erdogan qui va en faire
partie c'est pas de moi il faut le
donner directement dans les camps de
réfugiés en turquie
on sait que c'est mal utilisé les trois
milliards ils sont prêts à l'utiliser à
bord on sent pas deuxièmement on va les
donner au gouvernement d'erdogan moi
j'ai pas beaucoup de confiance là dedans
plutôt les utiliser pour donner un comme
on dit une assistance financière directe
aux réfugiés dans les camps parce que la
réalité pour le moment est la suivante
c'est qu'ils doivent survivre avec 7
dollars par mois comment vous pouvez
survivre avec 7 dollars par mois dans ce
conte c'est impossible et donc
l'utilisation de deux milliards de ces
trois milliards d'euros pour donner une
assistance directe aux réfugiés dans la
possibilité d'augmenter ce montant d'une
manière dramatique de 10 fois de plus ça
va devenir 100 euros environ à chaque
réfugié et ça va diminuer la pression
anvers s'est réfugié de 2,2 de sortir de
ces camps et de venir en europe là c'est
la meilleure solution pour résoudre un
autre problème
guy verhofstadt avec les autres
vous savez ces centres de répartition
sont enregistrés et orienter les
migrants à le plan européen prévoit 11
dans les deux pays qui se trouve en
première ligne l'italie et la grèce
on en fait seuls 4 fonctionne trois en
italie et seulement 1 en grèce la grèce
qui voit pourtant arrivé 90% des
réfugiés les graisses 10 nous avons
besoin de plus de gardes côtes
l'aide des pays européens est trop
longue à venir on a des chiffres à guy
verhofstadt sept pays non dépêché aucun
agent pour faire fonctionner les
hotspots d'autres états se sont contenté
d'envoyer des renforts qui se comptent
sur les doigts d'une main 80 agents pour
la belgique 2 pour la finlande avec 59
agents je crois que c'est la france qui
en envoie le plus c'est normal ne s'est
pas normal et mais la seule solution
pour en finir avec cette ce petit jeu
c'est de créer une instance une agence
au niveau européenne parce que si une
agence de nuire aux européennes existent
eux ils vont avoir le budget pour
engager les gens et obliger les états à
envoyer les agents et les fonctionnaires
ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
mais si on la laisse dépendre chaque
fois de la volonté des états membres
d'une wii d'une prise de position à
l'unanimité des 28 ça ne peut pas
fonctionner on a quand même la preuve
maintenant qu'il ne faut pas moins
d'intégration européenne est plus
d'intégration européenne et que cette
intégration européenne ne doit pas
dépendre d'une décision à 28 à
l'unanimité mais que ça doit être ça
doit dépendre d'une agence d'une entité
au niveau européen au niveau fédéral au
niveau communautaire
ça s'appelle fonctionner l'autre
actualité européenne guy verhofstadt
c'est le break site à l'idée que la
grande bretagne pourrait sortir de
l'europe
est-ce que c'est envisager un référendum
un bientôt en grande bretagne est-ce que
c'est envisageable selon vous ce que
c'est possible mais possible on sait
jamais ce que les britanniques vont
décider les citoyens parce que
naturellement si on raconte toujours
dead des choses négatives sur l'union
européenne
alors on peut s'attendre à une vote
négatif à la fin parce que si on
explique toujours oui ça ne font pas
bien l'union
il ya la crise des réfugiés la crise
sécuritaire la crise géopolitique à la
fin qu'est ce que disent les les
citoyens ça fonctionne pas de là d'une
bonne façon donc on est contre donc il
faut faire attention
surtout que au niveau géopolitique ce
serait dramatique si la grande bretagne
son sort de l'union européenne le seul
qui va qui ne va pas se plaindre c'est
poutine parce qu'il aime une europe
divisée entre d'une part la grande
bretagne et d'autre part le continent
donc il faut l'éviter mais il faut
l'éviter comment il ne faut pas suivre
certains hommes politiques britanniques
dans tous leurs ce qu'ils me david
cameron premier ministre britannique a
l'air a décidé dit que si les
travailleurs européens qui
s'installerait en grande bretagne ne
doivent pas bénéficier d'allocations
pendant quatre ans à 86 ils demandent
une sorte d'intervention
est-ce que c'est acceptable sénèque
acceptable si c'est la commission qui
les décident ou qui le propose
parce que la commission est le garant
des intérêts de l'union européenne ici
il ya vraiment un problème c'est à la
commission dans des idées par la grande
bretagne parce que si c'est la grande
bretagne qui ont décidé on va nous tuer
l'union européenne et en plus ce qu'il
ne faut pas non plus ses deux commencé à
réécrire l'histoire de l'union
européenne avec cette négociation par
exemple dire oui cette idée d'avoir une
europe de plus en plus intégré
ce n'est pas nécessaire ce n'est plus
nécessaire au moment on à la crise des
réfugiés l'acquis sécuritaire la crise
géopolitique il nous faut justement plus
d'europe plus d'intégration européenne
et pas moi guy verhostadt vous êtes un
personnage important ici au parlement
européen a un poids lourd on a
l'impression que les français peut-être
les belges aussi s'intéressent pas trop
à votre action à l'action du parlement
européen comment vous l'expliquez se
désintéresse des êtres désaffection sais
pas je ne sais pas je pense qu'il ya de
plus en plus de ce que c'est pas ça
aussi le mâle européen ouais qu'il n'y a
pas assez de citoyens qui les suivent
qu'ils à ce qui se passe mais il ya
quand même de plus en plus de citoyens
comment je rencontre qui suivent ce qui
se passe au niveau européen parce qu'ils
savent très bien que les problèmes des
changements climatiques le problème
sécuritaire le problème des réfugiés le
problème des conflits dans notre
voisinage ne peuvent pas être résolus
par des états membres tout seul même pas
par la grande bretagne par la france
qu'il faut une coopération qu'il faut
une union européenne qui à force
et c'est une bataille très dure parce
que il faut se battre contre des
nationalistes et populistes qui veulent
expliquer aux gens et qu'ils sont en
train d'expliquer les gens que de se
retirer derrière les frontières
nationales ça va résoudre tous les
problèmes du monde
ce qui naturellement l faut il
verhofstadt merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation c'est toujours un plaisir de
vous recevoir c'est la fin de repas bio
merci de nous avoir suivi la semaine
prochaine vous retrouvez nos ramadi
d'ici là bonne cuite des programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires et la rtbf
bail